قالت الاداره العسكريه والمدنيه الروسيه
في زابوروجيا ان الجيش الاوكراني يستعد
لبدء المرحله الثانيه من الهجوم المضاد
ويحاول القيام بعمليات استطلاع ويدفع
بمزيد من التعزيزات الى المقاطعه من جهه
قال موقع ريدوفكا الروسي ان معارك محتدمه
تدور بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
محور اريخوف جنوبيه مقاطعه زابوريا اضاف
الموقع ان القوات الاوكرانيه استطاعت
التقدم قليلا باتجاه بلده
بريوتونوي وقرب بلده نوفودو غرب بمقاطعه
وفي محور اوغليدار اعلنت القوات المواليه
لروسيا سيطرتها على دبابه فرنسيه من طراز
ام اكس خلال معارك مع القوات الاوكرانيه
معنا من دونيتك مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
ومن امتياز مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
وسنبدا معك عمر كيف عاشت العاصمه
الاوكرانيه على وقع هذه الموجه الليليه من
الهجمات بالطائرات المسيره التي نفذتها
روسيا
عند الساعه الثانيه والنصف فجرا اليوم دوت
صافرات الانذار في مختلفه مناطق العاصمه
لفتره طويله وعادت مره اخرى عند الساعه
الرابعه فجرا بالتوقيت المحلي ليكشف ضوء
النهار عن هجمات شلتها القوات الروسيه
باستخدام طائرات ايرانيه الصنع مسيره من
طراز شاهد العسكريه هنا في كييف تكتمت حتى
الان على موقعي هذا الهجوم وقالت فقط في
بيان مقتضب لها ان هذا الهجوم ادى الى
تسبب باضرار في منازل المدنيين ومن ذلك
الحين لم تنشر اي وسائل اعلام رسميه او
حتى غير الرسميه صورا عن مكان هذا الهجوم
ولكن المشير ايضا الى هذه الانباء العاجله
التي
تشير الى
وصولنسكي الى مدينه الى مقاطعه اوديسا في
الجنوب في زياره غير معلنه هذه الزياره
تتزامل مع العيد الوطني
البحريه الاوكرانيه التي تقع قاده قاده
القوات البحريه فهناك استعرض ايضا قدرات
البحريه الاوكرانيه في تلك المنطقه
واستعرض مع هؤلاء القاده الميدانيين
الاخطار التي تصل الى اوكرانيا او تشهدها
اوكرانيا قادمه من البحر الاسود كذلك كان
هناك هجوم
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ من
طراز كليبر من البحر الاسود شنتتها القوات
الاوكرانيه على مناطق مختلفه اليوم كان
هناك نوع من التفاؤل او حتى
الفخر الى حد ما من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
الذي تحدث عنه تقدم ملحوظ حققته القوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه بخموت هذا التقدم جاء
على لسان المتحدث باسم قياده المنطقه
الشرقيه
وقال ان ناهيه الاركان ستشرح ببيان مفصل
كل هذه المناطق التي حازتها القوات
الاوكرانيه والتي سعت القوات الروسيه منذ
ساعات الصباح لاستعاده السيطره عليها دون
جدوى وفقا لتعبيره ايضا كان هناك احاديث
لاقاده عسكريين في الجبهات الجنوبيه تحدى
اشار فيه الى هجمات التي شنت على كل منا
وايضا على مقاطعه خرسون في جنوب البلاد
كذلك
القوات الاوكرانيه تشير الى احباطها
الكثير من الهجمات التي شنتها القوات
الروسيه في محور لمن كوبينس واختم هذه
المداخله بحديث قبل قليل بتغريده للمستشار
في مكتب الرئاسي
الذي تحدث مره اخرى عن وجود اتخاذ قرار
دولي بشان ما يحدث من تهديدات في محطه
وقال ان اوكرانيا تطالب العالم ببيان موحد
حول هذا يشير الى ان اي هجوم ارهابي كما
وصفه على هذه المحطه يقابله استخدام او
يعني استخدام روسيا لاسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه
وان على العالم التحرك سريعا ضد هذا
التهديد ولكنه كما قاله وفقا للتغريده
تستقبل اوكرانيا يستجاب لاوكرانيا بصمت
مطبق من العالم